[Musique]
les productions de vélo a chuté parce
que les vélos sont fabriqués à 90 % en
asie et lors de la fermeture des usines
en asie
la production s'est stoppée net donc ça
à côté d'une forte demande en vélo en
france fête du vélo est détaché pour pas
les citer fournissent aussi les marques
de vélo entre les attacher à partir du
moment où les caisses détachées sont en
pénurie les chaînes sont bloqués donc on
peut plus faire reculer
effectivement là habituellement pour
faire un coup on est on est remplie
d'antivol et le porte bagages
actuellement les rayons sont vides et
pour les casques les casques vélos
enfants surtout on a on a eu beaucoup de
demandes et beaucoup de livraisons sur
octobre novembre
là sur le mois de décembre on va
commencer vraiment en rupture
actuellement les outils de production de
nos fournisseurs principalement sur le
casque et les antivols se trouvant en
asie sont des outils qui sont
difficilement localisable dans des
délais très courts de manière les
marques pour l'instant non pas n'est pas
le souhait de re localiser sur leur
démarche et leur père
[Musique]
des prochains à pro sur les modèles
phares des gammes quelle que soit la
marque c'est juillet août septembre
voire octobre 2021 et pour les vélos
vraiment demander qui ont déjà été
commandés on bascule sur mars 2022